à
il ne faut pas longtemps aux voyageurs
qui traversent lancy pour s'apercevoir
de la beauté de son architecture
nancy ville des métiers d'art est l'une
des plus belles villes du nord-est de la
france c'est ici le point de départ du
gr 534 le sentier de randonnée créer et
balisé par le club vosgien il relie la
place stanislas de nancy jusqu'à la
place kléber de strasbourg soit 271 km
les randonneurs l'appelle le stanislas
kléber nous vous invitons à nous suivre
sur ce sentier nous avons rencontré des
personnages attachants traversé des
paysages magnifiques parfois insolites
mais tous chargés d'histoire
pour notre départ de nancy la place
stanislas ainsi nommé à la mémoire du
duc de lorraine s'est habillé d'un
magnifique jardin éphémère
l'hôtel de ville et les bâtiments qui
l'entourent ont la particularité d'être
reliés les uns aux autres par les
magnifiques grille de jean lamour cette
place fait partie d'un ensemble urbain
classée au patrimoine mondial de
l'unesco en la traversant on comprend la
fierté des nancéens qui l'ont surnommée
la plus belle place du monde
nous sortons de la ville et le gr 534
nous emmène dans la campagne lorraine
nous faisons une première halte dans un
petit village du lunévillois à gondrin
que son afin de rencontrer sonia
copropriétaire de la ferme du port qui
dort
sous ce nom évocateur sonia et thierry
font partie de ces jeunes éleveurs qui
par goût des traditions ont décidé de
pratiquer un élevage extensif et
respectueux
il tenait vraiment à coeur c'était le
cochon faire de l'élevage de cochons
c'est un animal qui est hyper attachons
et avec lequel j'ai toujours voulu
travailler
on a choisi de travailler avec le porc
gascon donc c'est une race du sud ouest
c'est un port rustique et qui est élevé
en plein air donc en lorraine c'est
assez rare d'élever les ports en plein
air
c'est un port qui a une croissance qui
est très longtemps donc la viande a le
temps de se faire et donc nous on les
abat à partir de l'âge de 20 ans ce qui
nous donne une viande plus grâce certes
mais il ya plus de goût et en fait qui
est beaucoup plus rouge ça plaît oui ça
plaît vraiment bien en fait souvent donc
soit les gens nous disent c'est vraiment
le port qu'elle faisait ma grand-mère ou
alors maintient le port a du goût alors
donc on transforme tout à la ferme j'ai
un laboratoire agréé par les services
vétérinaires et donc je découpe et puis
je transforme en charcuterie pièce
viande fraîche que je vend sur les
marchés c'est exclusivement des marchés
de producteurs
les orges céréales herbe et pâturages
c'est le menu quotidien des cochons de
sonia à la fin du port qui dort au
cultive des dizaines d'hectares
uniquement destiné à nourrir tout ce
petit monde une chose est sûre c'est
toujours là ils ne mangeront jamais de
soja tpour projet d'être ferme
pédagogique
donc pour l'instant je reçois un petit
peu de classe mais je voudrais
développer cette activité là ben
justement moi ce qui m'a fait être
agricultrice c'est être en contact avec
les animaux j'ai une certaine idée en
fait de l'élevage et j'ai envie de la
faire partager quoi donc de partager mes
valeurs et donc pour ça il ya les
marchés il ya la rencontre avec le
consommateur mais il ya aussi elle va
tout l'aspect pédagogique qu'on peut
avoir avec les enfants quoi et ça c'est
vraiment important parce que c'est les
consommateurs de demain et c'est les
citoyens de demain donc c'est bien
qu'ils aient un autre regard sur
l'agriculture que ce qu'on peut leur
montrer habituellement quoi
japon risque
cet aveu garçons nos sacs à dos remplis
des spécialités de sonia nous reprenons
le gr 534 les éoliennes qui bordent le
chemin semble nous dire au revoir tandis
que nous prenons la direction de la
moselle nous gagnons le plateau lorrain
et là commence la forêt c'est sûr nous
sommes maintenant dans les vosges du
nord le stanislas kléber passe par saint
quirin presque une évidence car ce
village organise chaque année le
festival international de la randonnée
qui attire des milliers de marcheurs
durant trois jours nous faisons un bout
de chemin avec les membres du club
vosgien qui ose aussi suivent le
parcours jusqu'à strasbourg et au bout
d'un sentier nous arrivons à la
mystérieuse autres chapelles qui domine
saint quirin l'ats roland randonneurs et
historien amateur qui connaît
parfaitement ce lieu chargé d'histoire
et de croyances nous raconte ses
origines
sur la colline qui domine donc le
village de saint quirin c'est ici que
tout a commencé
lorsque sont arrivés en 1050 les
reliques des saints qui s'appelait
terrain ces reliques ont été déposés
dans cette chapelle
en lançant 32 quand le tribun qui ravit
dans les prisons de rome le pape
alexandre faire des miracles et même
guérir sa propre fille et fut
bouleversée et se convertit au
christianisme il fut alors arrêtez
martyrisé et exécutés sans jamais renier
sa foi quelques dizaines d'années plus
tard qui rend fut canonisé
devin saint saint quirin aurait-il
hérité du pouvoir de guérison du pape
alexandre
depuis plus de neuf siècles ces reliques
sont précieusement gardés dans le
prieuré et elles sont vénérés d'après la
légende elle aurait des pouvoirs il faut
dire que 5 a toujours eu la renommée
d'être un saint guérisseur et notamment
ils viennent et c'est une maladie les
écrouelles les écrouelles qui sont une
maladie des ganglions du coup tout
simplement en appliquant sur les peler
une ou plusieurs feuilles de chêne
trempé précédemment dans l'eau de la
source de sa tirade
les gens viennent
aujourd'hui s'asperger d'eau lorsqu'il
veut le guérir d'une maladie c'est pour
ça qu'on appelle aujourd'hui cette
fontaine la fontaine miraculeuse
notre prochaine étape sera le rocher de
dabo mais impossible de s'y rendre sans
aller visiter les deux dernières maisons
troglodytes deux alertes logé dans le
rocher de grès rose au sommet du falcon
fels en 1872 38 personnes vivaient en
marge de la société dans ces maisons et
c'est en 1894 que l'administration
prussienne les filles dynamité obligeant
ainsi des habitants a résidé dans les
villages de la vallée deux maisonnettes
ont été soigneusement restauré à
l'identique les derniers à y avoir vécu
jusqu'en 1913 était un ermite kimber
très croyant et ses voisins un homme le
fait d'hommes martin et sa femme la
phase 4
en les visitant ne peut facilement
imaginer le mode de vie austère des
habitants de l'époque
ce lieu insolite nous offre un panorama
exceptionnel sur la vallée de la zorn et
le rocher de dabo à son sommet la
chapelle saint léon construite sur les
vestiges d'un château médiéval est un
hommage au pape léon 9 qui serait né à
dabo
mais autre chose au pied du rocher nous
intéresse le village de dabo vie charles
un artisan et artiste hors du commun
ce que j'ai fait deux ans qu on appelle
ça de la gravure maintenant il ya
largement plus compliqué à faire là je
vous ai montré quelque chose qui va
relativement assez vite mais pour
arriver à ce résultat là il faut quand
même compter une dizaine d'années de
pratique pour être autonome il n'y a
aucune école en france chez nous c'est
familial mon père était formé à valérie
salles enfin un autre père parce que
nous sommes quand même à cet enfant et
tous les sets ça avait gravé à l'époque
chacun sa manière chacun a son style
donc là il n'ya jamais d'école il ya
largement plus compliqué à faire si je
vous montre quelque chose comme ça donc
voyez les animaux les détails et tout ça
il faut travailler demel qui ont moins
de 2 cm environ de diamètre pour être
très précis mais il faut compter quand
même quelques heures de travail pour les
un article comme ça même si le savoir
faire familial est transmis de père en
fils charles a tout de même étudier le
métier il a dans sa poche les diplômes
de tailleur graveur sur verre et sur
cristal fort de 25 ans d'expérience ces
créations n'ont de limite que celle de
son imagination je pense que le plus
difficile dans notre métier c'est de
toujours trouver des nouveautés enfin
c'est une création points de vie de
travail ce qu on a rajouté après le
polissage donc entre autres ici le
feuillage de l'arbre nous tournons le
vase bas le tout va refléter dans les
boules en couleurs
même si les créations de charles ont
beaucoup de succès il ne reste plus
qu'une vingtaine de tailleur graveur sur
verre en france selon charles les écoles
se remplissent à nouveau et l'on devrait
pouvoir admirer bientôt des oeuvres
d'une nouvelle génération
sous un magnifique coucher de soleil sur
les vosges nous arrivons en alsace à
wangenbourg situé au coeur de ce que
l'on nomme la petite suisse
nous avons décidé de passer la nuit dans
l'un des nombreux gîtes de ce haut lieu
touristique
tout comme ses clients attablés l'équipe
apprécie aussi l'accueil et la
générosité de la cuisine alsacienne
traditionnelle
soupe de potimarron
bouchées à la reine et copieux dessert
un menu que nous digérons au bord de la
piscine chauffée du gîte avant de
regagner nos chambres
ce matin accompagné par les randonneurs
du club vosgien nous reprenons le
stanislas kléber nous prenons la
direction de wasselonne plus exactement
du kronthal une ancienne carrière de
grès rose d'où ont été extraites les
pierres pour la construction de la
cathédrale de strasbourg ce lieu est
devenu un terrain de jeu très prisé pour
les férus d escalade de la région par
cette belle journée la falaise est prise
d'assaut
thibault professeur d'escale inde est un
peu chez lui ici il connaît toutes les
voies de la falaise presque toute
l'année on peut le rencontrer et
profiter de sa connaissance du kronthal
qui se situe finalement très près de
strasbourg qui est accessible facilement
moi en tant que professionnel j'utilise
assez régulièrement avec des groupes
puisque ça permet aux jeunes qui sont en
cité ou qui n'ont pas toujours accès à
la nature d'accéder facilement à la
nature de découvrir l'escaladé d'une
très belle façon sans plus à 6 degrés
c'est une belle c'est une belle roche
c'est une roche assez particulière qu'on
trouve en alsace
sur les niveaux d' escalade qui vont de
3 à 9 ici on a des voix qui commence du
5 et qui vont jusqu'au 9 qui vont nous
permettre quand même d'avoir un niveau
quand même assez élevé sur les grimpeurs
qui viennent ici
ça reste dans la région
se porte bien connu est régulièrement
fait des actions pour nettoyer les sites
qui sont abîmés qui sont salis et on
fait au mieux pour limiter des traces un
peu blanche qu'on pourrait laisser nous
mêmes et chaque fois il ya des
collectifs de grimpeurs qui pensent à
trouver des solutions pour limiter notre
impact sur la nature et préserver notre
terrain de jeu le plus entier possible
le grand talent est devenu un sport
européen incontournable pour les
amateurs d'escaladé et on vient de
partout pour s'y mesurer
nous reprenons le sentier et traversons
les premières vignes de la route des
vins qui surplombe marlenheim mais ce
qui nous amène ici c'est un restaurant
le cerf un passage obligé pour les
gastronomes le cerf est devenu une
institution familiale reconnue comme
étant l'une des meilleures tables de la
région strasbourgeoise
dans ces lieux qui ont vu passer un
grand nombre de célébrités de têtes
couronnées michel husser chef étoilé est
la quatrième génération à continuer à
écrire l'histoire commencé par son
arrière-grand-père en 1930 on a eu
quelques hommes d'état notamment le plus
connu en alsace le père de l'europe
c'est jean monnet qui était même un ami
un ami personnel hamon n'a réellement
père est dans cette salle où nous sommes
avancées une petite salle à manger et je
pense qu'il ya eu des petites
discussions politiques au sujet de
l'europe
qui se sont déroulés ici bon s'était
jamais officiels ou officieux et puis
d'ailleurs où jean monnet même
habitaient dans la maison privée a à mon
arrière-grand-père
j'ai eu la chance d'aller au japon en
asie ou en amérique et j'ai toujours lu
là la curiosité de d'étudier leur
cuisine et puis bah ça m'a fait ouvrir
les yeux ça m'a donné d'autres données
d'autres goûts ça va donner d'autres
d'autres idées et donc en revenant ici
je veux aujourd'hui ben ce qu'il faut
que tu passes s'est gardé quand même là
l'identité alsacienne parce que c'est
très important retravaille des vieilles
recettes et au goût du jour restée
fidèle au terroir alsacien tout en
innovant justement aujourd'hui michel
nous a préparé une surprise un cours
particulier
donc je vais vous proposer aujourd'hui
une recette assez représentative de la
maison
qui allie à la fois le terroir la
modernité et puis l'ouverture on va dire
c'est des huîtres gratinées à la
choucroute nous faut une amende la
choucroute il nous faut les huîtres
alors moi j'aime bien les marraines les
spéciales de l'hérault un peu de crème
fouettée des échalotes du vin blanc
hier mais juste un petit peu
le choc ou d'un fonds alors on peut très
bien lisez la chronique
c'est juste un peu on comprend neuf
huîtres
mais de plus
en plus être là pas besoin de l'appui
réel et creux
donc la réduction a été fait j' ai
rajouté un petit peu drôle qui est un
mélange de farine et d'oeufs
et le beurre d'accord ça donne ce qu'on
l'appelle ainsi velouté
dans ce velouté va rajouter la crème
fouettée
va donner de la légèreté et un petit
sabayon
qui est un mélange donc de 9 2 jaunes
d'oeufs battus ce qui va nous permettre
de gratiné nous huîtres mon mélange des
deux
eric une cuillère voilà donc un appel
aux huîtres avec se mêleront
pour fumer un choix relativement épais
pour gratter ou bien
donc là je vais aller vers ce qu'on
l'appelle ce qu'on appelle pardon une
salamandre en fait c'est un gris qui va
nous permettre de gratiné l'huître et
lui donner une couleur peu d'oreille
rate un sport mme 8 puis en même temps
on va pouvoir juste procédé au dressage
moi je prends les doigts parce que j'ai
l'habitude de la chaleur situations
chaudes à mais sinon prenez une cuillère
monfils pause ça sur les sur les ags
voilà pourquoi on va décorer encore l'a7
avec des fleurs de capucine que j'ai
cueilli dans le jardin ce matin
tout est comme si nous à capucine via le
bouton qu'on peut transformer en cap ou
vinaigre et les feuilles empruntant qui
sont très bonnes si on peu poivrez et la
fleur de toute façon ce sont les fleurs
sont comestibles voilà donc je vous
souhaite bon appétit
c'est avec cette surprenante délicieuses
recettes en poche que nous reprenons
notre chemin nous laissons nos amis
randonneurs sur le stanislas kléber pour
nous rendre tous prêts à molsheim
et là nous nous rendons à la fondation
bugatti afin de visiter le musée du même
nom et admirer avec nostalgie ses
véhicules témoins du passé
en 1909 est horrible gatti et sa famille
s'installent à molsheim
pionnier dans l'industrie de
l'automobile il construira dans ses
usines les plus belles voitures
luxueuses et sportives considéré
aujourd'hui encore comme des oeuvres
d'art
mais nous design n'est pas la seule
raison du succès de ces autos bugatti
est dépositaire de plus de 1000
invention brevetée en mécanique
actuellement les voitures bugatti sont
toujours fabriqués à molsheim
l'homme qui aimait dire rien n'est trop
beau rien n'est trop cher à associer son
nom à jamais à la commune de molsheim
le gr 534 nous conduit à présent dans le
vignoble de la couronne d'or
à l'ouest de strasbourg le long des
vosges un ruban de collines couvertes de
vignobles s'offre à nous voilà les
terroirs de la couronne d'or elle réunit
19 communes qui élèvent des rieslings
paix silva nerfs des pinots noirs des
pinots blancs et bien d'autres avec le
même respect des traditions d'ailleurs
quatre d'entre eux sont classés grands
crus et là nous découvrons
scharrachbergheim situé au pied des
vignes
au coeur de ce village viticole un
restaurant pas comme les autres son
propriétaire daniel fils de vigneron
connaît bien la vigne mais il a aménagé
dans une partie de son restaurant de
coûts a brassé sa propre bière
par an était déjà vignerons mon
grand-père des vignerons et donc j'ai
déjà fait du pinot blanc et du riesling
et puis un beau jour où madiba il
faudrait pas tu peux pas être dans les
mines et au restaurant et donc on a
recommencé à faire de la bière
au milieu du vignoble si on peut dire
donc c'est de la bière non filtré non
pasteurisé c'est une bière fraîche voilà
vendus sur place
oh
sans
temps mort
exclu
c'est une bière par infusion combes et
le malt concassées on met de l'eau on
les refuse pendant 2h 2h30 et après donc
on le filtre
reprendre la première cuve et c'est là
qu'on donne donc on le cuit pendant à
peu près pendant une heure et demie etc
puis avec 12 lots entiers ferait donc là
une fermentation d'une semaine et donc
nous laisse encore posé de trois jours
et après on a notre bière fraîche donc
la renommée et fait part plus tôt la
bière et puis la tarte flambée ça suit
daniel a créé la bière de chaffar au yen
à la pêche à la châtaigne bière d'été
bière de noël il est constamment à la
recherche de nouvelles saveurs et dans
son restaurant les places au typiquement
alsacien est toujours servi en costume
traditionnel et c'est ça qui plaît
une autre curiosité nous emmène à
avolsheim
éloigné de la commune au bout d'une
longue allée entourée de champs se
dresse l'église saint-pierre appelé plus
communément le dôme petter
à
on sait qu'elle a été consacrée par le
pape alsacien léo 9 entre 1049 et 1053
alors que la légende la ferait remonter
à la fin de l'empiré romain ou aux
premiers siècles de la chrétienté elle
serait donc la plus vieille église
d'alsace en la visitant on peut
constater que le temps à oublier cette
petite église
à
le stanislas kléber rejoint maintenant
la rivière la bruche dont une partie est
détourné pour alimenter le canal de la
bruche un canal qui relie les carrières
de soultz les bains à strasbourg à la
demande de louis xiv l'ingénieur est
architecte vauban entreprend ce chantier
de canalisations long de 20 km et
parsemée de onze écluses le canal
servira à transporter des pierres des
vosges pour les fortifications de
strasbourg en 782 le canal est
opérationnel vauban n'aura mis qu'un an
pour réaliser ce projet titanesque
jusqu'en 1939 le canal servira au
transport de marchandises vers
strasbourg
le canal de la bruche est aujourd'hui
emprunter uniquement par les barques des
pêcheurs ou canoéiste en balade
nous embarquons avec alain président du
club de canoë de molsheim chaque été ils
organisent des sorties à la découverte
de la bruche et de sa biodiversité
au fil de l'eau
on est obligé de l'autre au point
d'arrivée ce qui nous permet de vraiment
décompresser et vraiment être en
communication avec la nature on
sensibilise les enfants au respect de la
nature respect de l'autre puis une
syrienne partie pédagogique qui sert le
maniement du bateau donc
on fait découverte de la faune et de la
flore
on va retrouver des martins pêcheurs des
singles plongeurs et du héron cendré
plus tout ce qui est canards oies
on apprend à reconnaître les plantes
invasives l'eau envahissante de la
région type renouée du japon balsamine
de l'himalaya mais on les sensibilise
justement à tout ce qui est propre et et
au niveau de l'eau au niveau des
détritus qu'on ramasse les nettoyer
notre lieu de vie peu notre lieu de vie
quoi le long de la bruche alain est un
peu comme le gardien de la nature ces
initiatives sont relayés depuis 30 ans
et les résultats sont maintenant
visibles
on a remarqué qu'il ya de la renoncule
doux qui repousse au niveau de molsheim
que ça faisait moi je n'avais jamais vu
depuis 30 ans a fait il n'y avait jamais
eu de renoncules dos maintenant depuis
trois quatre ans on arrive à avoir de la
reconnaissons qu'une eau donc c'est la
propreté de l'eau qui a permis qu'elle
revienne
c'est un dépaysement on n'est pas obligé
de quitter sa région ou de quitter la
france pour avoir vraiment des
sensations et de voir que la nature est
vraiment belle surtout quand elle est
située au bord de l'eau
notre balade sur l'eau nous emmène
jusqu'à ergersheim
là alain nous dépose devant le
restaurant au canal qui sera notre
dernière étape
ce restaurant créé à l'époque des
bateliers était le dernier lieu où nous
pouvait boire et manger avant de
rejoindre strasbourg
depuis la piste cyclable qui longe le
canal amène surtout une clientèle fait
de cyclistes de promeneurs et deux
randonneurs
d'après frédéric son aïeul aurait ouvert
ce restaurant avant 1881 ce jeune
cuisinier a naturellement repris le
flambeau et perpétue une longue
tradition familiale on continue toujours
à faire notre tarte flambée tarte forme
et dont la recette est toujours la même
celle le cab est créé mon père moi j'ai
voulu apporter une petite touche trouvée
des techniques de grandes maisons qu'on
pouvait adapter à des produits un peu
plus simple
après avoir fait son tour de france et
travailler dans les plus grands
restaurants
frédéric a ramené un savoir-faire et
autres spécialités qu'il ajoute à la
cuisine de ses aïeux
là pour le poisson j'ai été très inspiré
par mon passage dans le sud de la france
d'alléger les sauces de ne pas utiliser
de beurre dans la confection de mets
sauce uniquement une crème d'une crème
label rouge plus digeste
le but ici c'est de durer 2 et de
transmettre quelque part je suis la
sixième génération en espérant pouvoir
transmettre le restaurant à la septième
jeu ça je le dis souvent le restaurant
ne m'appartiennent ne m'appartient pas
vraiment
on me le on me le donne un temps donné
pour que je leur donne
si possible mieux en meilleur état et en
état de marche à la génération d'après
c'est ça le but
à voir le succès de frédérick ses aïeux
peuvent être tranquilles l'héritage est
entre de bonnes mains
nous reprenons une dernière fois le gr
534 mais avait l'eau cette fois cette
piste cyclable très fréquenté et longue
de 18 km permet aux strasbourgeois de
s'échapper de la ville
nous arrivons au barrage vauban
construit en grès rose des vosges et
nous rentrons dans strasbourg capitale
de l'alsace et carrefour de l'europe
nous nous mêlons aux touristes qui
flânent dans la petite france le plus
vieux quartier de strasbourg bordé par
une charmante rivière lille
puis nous découvrons la place kléber
situé au coeur même de la ville et qui
est aussi le terminus de notre gr ce à
134 notre aventure prend fin ici
cette place dédiée au général
strasbourgeois jean baptiste kléber
renferme son cercueil un hommage un
général qui avant de mourir eu plus de
gloire que bonaparte